the Joe Rogan experience tax-exempt
status for religions yet that one
because otherwise why can't I start a
religion right now and get tax exempt
status why can't you you tell me
Scientology can do it how many people
makes a religion do you have a number
tell me give me your number tell me what
your numbers are King what how do you
know whether or not someone's legit how
do you decide it no one should be tax
exempt especially someone who's taking
in [ __ ] [ __ ] ton piles of money if
you're some sort of church or whatever
and you're getting donations in the
millions and millions of dollars and
you're like one of them Benny Hinn
[ __ ] out there driving a Bentley
Amazon Inc paid zero federal taxes in
2017 gets seven hundred eighty nine
million windfall from new tax law they
paid zero doesn't work yeah that's Dutch
didn't happen either but the idea is
that a corporation now this is not my
idea so don't think I'm supporting this
I have to preface this but the idea is
that corporations shouldn't pay taxes
because all the individuals who are
making money in that corporation already
pay taxes this is the argument that I've
heard and that made me go oh okay and
the argument was why did Peter Schiff
did he say that to me I don't think was
on the air might not have been him [ __ ]
anyway sidetrack the idea is that a
corporation is not an individual so why
should it pay taxes it's not a person
it's a conglomeration of people those
people already pay taxes the corporation
has money that it's that's piled up
right and then like it's got a value and
it's got its on the stock market and it
goes up and it goes down and you know
and they're always kind of looking to
improve their their bottom line and
universal constant growth but it's not a
person but we I feel like corporations
have gotten rights like people yeah over
the last 20 plus years you're right yeah
they have they gotten rights in terms of
how much they can donate to charities -
excuse me political campaigns and that
used to be
not the case they used to have a limit
and now they are like an individual in
which they can donate as much money as
they want to political campaigns and
doesn't a corporation also act to defend
itself sort of like yes can you do that
make sure that's true that corporations
they can donate as much as they want to
political campaigns now I think I want
to say this is like during the Abama
administration Obama yeah I think this
was during the Obama administration it's
a disturbing one that's a disturbing one
to me because that is a that is a that's
a lot of influence for someone like a
Amazon I don't think Amazon is evil
what's the limit wanted to be I don't
know me if the limits like well that's
you know maxing $30,000 there's no limit
gonna be a limit there should be a limit
yeah but I don't think there is it has
to be well I don't know how sad is it
that I don't know I should know okay see
what we got I've seen various things the
one I'm seeing right now is that an S
corp can deduct up to 50% of its
adjusted gross income to be as a
qualified no how much money can no there
was a law passed and I'm looking it's
not popping up how much money there was
a law passed that stated how much money
a corporation can donate to political
campaigns that was very specific that a
corporation is seen as an individual
when I look up that corporations seen as
individual for donation political
campaigns it was just it's not anybody's
good in anybody's interest that these
huge companies like Amazon or anything
that size that is [ __ ] billions of
dollars that they should just be able to
get together and influence a politician
with a [ __ ] ton of money and then the
politician does their bidding and it
helps them be bigger and stronger and it
maybe [ __ ] over some people gotta be
really careful about that because the
politicians could find a way of arguing
it well I could see but what is that how
he would vote without that influence No
so all these politicians are get into
those positions are all just influence
peddlers
just peddling influence the saying
listen you know if you help me I'll help
you scratch my back I scratch yours
they're not looking out for the people
that voted them in at all they're
looking out for the people that paid all
the money to make them more prominent so
that people would vote them in its very
sneaky like it should have been fixed a
long time ago it's really if you think
of all the [ __ ] like insider trading
that is illegal like if if Jamie really
did know something about Facebook and
then he told us and like hey dude shits
going down get rid of all your Facebook
stock right now and you and I went crazy
and got rid of it we ki get in trouble
that's like Paul Ryan's in trouble for
right now
something thing he got I suppose it was
he's sold a bunch of stock so someone
told them and he bailed yeah see how is
that illegal but it's not illegal to
influence politicians and and have
corporations spend [ __ ] tons of money
and then obviously get preferential
treatment and obviously get laws pushed
here it is Paul Ryan sold shares on same
day as private briefing of banking
crisis whoops that seems like a dumb
move dude Wow you gotta take the hit
sign move now you got to take the hit
there fellow you can't do that that's
terrible
somebody told me you better sell your
Toys R Us stock right now ha ha that's
what I hear
but this thing about this guy like when
can he like trade those stocks
I don't know how long have to way cuz
that's a Martha Stewart got in trouble
for it see right well she lied about
doing it yeah she got like they found a
note that had like the information on
her something god damn my memories dog
[ __ ] lately they just have real quick on
the tax thing I think there is a limit
but then that's why super PACs became a
thing so you can donate to another
organization that's not directly to them
and then a group and give the money as
they saw and it's just a workaround you
know what the limit is though it's I
believe it's 2700 for an individual and
then there's like for a company can give
like up to ten thousand dollars or
something so it's 2700 for an individual
that's interesting her election still a
lot of money but not as much money as
you would think it would being right
like you would think it'd be like a
million
yeah you know there's a bunch of [ __ ]
whackadoo as it would give a million the
thing is man there's weird things that
happen with politicians that you don't
factor in when you think about bribery
and one of the weird ones is did you
ever see that movie about the financial
crisis which one was it called
mmm inside job
inside job it's [ __ ] amazing but one
of the things that it details is how
many of these guys were professors that
were making these suggestions like
working as consultants to the government
making these suggestions that why not to
be horribly irresponsible financially
and then those guys get giant jobs
afterwards that pay [ __ ] millions of
dollars and you're like wait a minute
what happened here you're a professor
you made these sort of you know weird
suggestions that if you looked at like
in the in the movie inside job he goes
over it with these professors like what
how the [ __ ] could you have thought this
why did you push this like why were you
why were you guys promoting that and
then they go on to get these gigantic
[ __ ] jobs at banks and you're like oh
this is crazy it's like a clear path
like do the right thing here and then
you're gonna make five million dollars a
year here and so they all do it and this
movie is really good because in one of
the scenes he's talking to one of these
big-time bank guys and in the middle of
talking to him that guy realizes what's
going on and he gets a real hostile but
he keeps going he'll like his arrogance
allows him to like keep battling this
guy but he keeps like looking dumber and
dumber because the guy was doing the
interview is really good the guy who put
together this documentaries really good
it's an it's a fascinating documentary
that gives you a real insight into how
complicated complicated and [ __ ]
distorted this system is like it's very
distorted for those people that are just
like those rich banker guys all they're
doing is moving money actually have all
that money and what do you do I've been
put money over here and I get it over
pick it up
aren't you glad you're not doing that
you know I don't understand it
[Applause]